what advice would you give me as someone  who hasn't really found a place  religiously but who is very much whose  religion religious inclinations very  much affect their conservative ideals i  was an atheist from 13 until about  uh  23.  pretty firmly in that camp  so you're ahead of the curve to to  recognize  i do have this inclination i have a kind  of natural longing for god as does  everybody it's just part of the human  condition and i don't quite know how to  make sense of it intellectually but i  don't know i don't know where i am  my  advice to you would be  to  follow the inclination  you don't need to make any grand  statements you don't you don't even  necessarily need to choose your creed  just yet but but i would follow that  inclination i would behave as though god  exists it'll keep you out of trouble in  your teenage years and also it's it's  the right thing to do